the families of these young people say
that each of them has developed an
addiction that cost them their lives and
that they represent just a fraction lost
every year through suicides linked to
problem gambling
today's six mothers arrived in Downing
Street with Tori MP Ian Duncan Smith
with a letter calling for change
it should have on the bottom of any
gambling advert it should say gambling
kills
K Wadsworth sold her home to pay for her
daughter's gambling debts before
Kimberly aged just 32 took her own life
you asked me the question how much did
she spend how much was she in debt for
it doesn't matter whether it was one
million whether it was one pound she
paid the ultimate price which was her
life
while the gambling world has moved with
dizzying Pace into the technological ERA
with casinos moving to our phones
legislation has been glacial
since the gambling review was published
in 2019 there has been a succession of
delays partly due to political turmoil
there's been nine different ministers in
charge of the brief in that time but it
does seem like now the white paper is
about to be published if not before
Christmas then soon after
these campaigners want the bill to
include a statutory Levy to raise money
from the industry to pay for independent
information education and addiction
treatment there's already a voluntary
system but Liz Ritchie who lost her son
jack says it's not robust what's wrong
with the with the gambling messaging as
it is I mean they do do a lot of
anti-gambling messaging well it's not
really anti-cambling is it I mean it's
sort of when it stops being fun just try
and stop or take time to think you
cannot take time to think when you have
the equivalent of a heroin addiction
the industry says the number of problem
gamblers are reducing and they give 110
million pounds a year to gamble aware
they add gamblerware is responsible for
independently Distributing research
education and treatment funds to
services and Charities British gambling
council members have no formal or
informal role with gamblerware and have
no say on who receives donated money or
how it's spent
but both industry and campaigners expect
change
the key areas that we need to see is to
curtail the promotional levels that go
on particularly to younger people and
the second thing is to make sure that
those who are already damaged can get
treatment because it's being paid for by
those who damage them
you'll find out soon whether he and
these mothers have convinced the
government Jason Farrell Sky News